in this lesson we're going to go over
the claisen condensation reaction we'll
discuss some important considerations
and review the mechanism in this
reaction will have two esters reacting
and here I've shown ethyl acetate twice
I've just shown it in two different
colors so we can see where the new bonds
form when our ester is first treated
with a base here we'll use sodium
ethoxide and then treated with one
equivalent of acid will form this
compound that contains one ester and we
can see from the blue side the ester
group has been lost so we get a compound
with an ester and a ketone and our new
bond is shown in red before we tackle
the mechanism I need to tell you a
couple important considerations about
the base in this reaction first of all
the base should match the ester so what
do I mean by the base matching the ester
well over here we have ethyl esters
notice we have the eto we could have an
Emmy O or maybe some other ester we have
an ethyl group so we use sodium ethoxide
as the base let me show you why this is
important say we begin with this ethyl
ester but we treat it with sodium
methoxide here the compound can undergo
a transesterification reaction where
this ome can attack here replacing the
ethyl group so as you can imagine this
gets a little messy we'd have some
swapping of the esters maybe we'd retain
some of the ethyl group we'll get our
new product forming and it'd be a
mixture of methyl and ethyl esters over
here so that's just some pretty sloppy
chemistry another consideration is that
the base cannot be hydroxide if we
consider using this ethyl ester as a
starting material again and we treat
this with something like sodium
hydroxide or potassium hydroxide we will
actually get cleavage to the carboxylate
now the claisen condensation occurs by
forming enolates we're going to form an
enolate here attack and I'll show you
that mechanism in just one second
however if we cleave to our carboxylate
we have
with a negative charge on it carboxylic
acids because they deprotonate they're
really hard to analyze and so we really
want to maintain the ester in the
starting material so make sure your base
matches your ester so we don't get
transesterification and that your base
does not cleave your ester all right
let's take a look at this mechanism so
I've redrawn our ester to show this
proton here this proton is a bit acidic
it has a pKa of around 24 now I'm going
to treat this with sodium ethoxide I'll
treat the sodium as a spectator ion and
just show ro et minus this will
deprotonate this proton forming an
enolate so we're taking off this proton
in these electrons that are left behind
become a lone pair on carbon this
enolate
has resonance and that's what makes this
proton quite acidic in the first place
we can show our enolate with a
carbon-carbon double bond here and push
these electrons up onto oxygen now it
doesn't really matter if we show this
form or this form of the enolate because
these are resonance structures both of
these contribute to the overall
structure and us drawing this and this
is just our best way of representing on
paper what the enolate looks like it's
actually somewhat intermediate to these
two structures now our enol a reacts
with another molecule of our starting
material notice where the new bond forms
so this enolate needs to attack using
this carbon atom and it attacks at the
carbonyl carbon to make the bond we can
represent this as the electrons pushing
down from oxygen kicking out this bond
here which attacks at the carbonyl
carbon and finally we push electrons up
onto oxygen so we don't make five bonds
to carbon here this forms an
intermediate in which this sp2 Center
becomes sp3 this has tetrahedral
geometry and we call this a tetrahedral
intermediate tetrahedral intermediates
are intermediate so they are not
Gabel so what's going to happen is this
negative charge on oxygen is going to
push back down kicking out Oh et - as a
leaving group now a thocks ID is not a
good leaving group in sn1 and sn2
reactions but once we have all this
negative charge built up on the molecule
and we're treating this with sodium
ethoxide as base it's okay to kick this
out as a leaving group and this does
indeed occur this gives us our
dicarbonyl compound now you may think
we're done but this is not quite the end
of the story with this mechanism we have
two protons right here on the carbon
between the carbonyls since these
hydrogen atoms are surrounded by these
carbonyls these electron withdrawing
groups these are more acidic than this
proton was in the starting material in
fact they have a pKa of about 11 the
conjugate acid of a thocks I'd ethanol
has a pKa of 16 so in this step the
equilibrium actually favors the full
deprotonation of this compound by the
ethoxide that's in solution so in the
final step of our mechanism this proton
is removed so in this step we use Oh 18
- to do our deprotonation in this step
we generate a molecule of Oh a T - but
then we have to use it up completely so
this reaction is not catalytic it
actually requires one full equivalent of
sodium ethoxide and this is why we need
a second step where we add in one
equivalent of acid not enough to cleave
our ester just just enough to neutralize
the negative charge of this enolate and
get our final product in this example
the same substrate reacted twice to form
our product the cross claisen would be
where we have two different esters as
starting materials now this reaction
isn't super synthetically useful but in
case you encounter it I want to show you
some examples of substrates that could
potentially undergo with the crossed
claisen and these are going to be
substrates without enol
or protons so we'll need to have one
reactant that has ena liza below tons
and one that does not
so here are four potential substrates
for the crossed claisen reaction notice
there are no hydrogen atoms alpha to the
carbonyl group and this one might be a
little bit deceiving here we have this
aldehyde like hydrogen those are never
acidic remember we need to have a carbon
adjacent and it's the hydrogen's on that
carbon that are acidic it's always
better with an example so let's go ahead
and look at an example of a cross
claisen using one of these substrates
and there's just a little bit more to
talk about with this as well here we
have ethyl propionate and let's react
this with ethyl benzoate so this is the
substrate that we're going to analyze
but notice that we have this large
phenyl ring here this substrate is
actually quite sterically hindered and
we saw in this reaction that we can have
a claisen reaction of one substrate with
itself so it's actually more likely that
this will analyze and then react with an
unreacted molecule of itself since this
is harder to attack so what we need to
do is use an excess of this compound so
as soon as some of this analyzes it
finds our ethyl benzoate and does the
crossed claisen in our first step the
ethyl propanol a in Eliza's there are
many molecules of the ethyl benzoate
around because we're using an excess
just gonna breathe you to ring as pH
since it's easier to write the enolate
attacks the carbonyl pushing the
electrons onto oxygen and forming our
tetrahedral intermediate will then kick
out our leaving group forming the
dicarbonyl compound that gets
deprotonated by the sodium ethoxide in
solution and so we carefully treat this
compound with an equivalent of acid to
re pro in a our enol ii in this lesson
we looked at the mechanism of the
claisen condensation we learned that
base choice is important the base should
match the ester on the molecule and we
shouldn't use hydroxide because that can
cleave esters we also learned that the
Krauss claisen isn't the best synthetic
reaction however it can be done with
substrates that don't contain any
enolizable protons if they're used in
excess as ever thanks for watching if
you learn something like this video and
if you'd like to do more chemistry with
me subscribe and click that notification
bell